races with us in Nebraska hi grace how
are you good thank you for taking my
call
sure I'll help um my question is I'm
actually my husband and I are in baby
steps - we are just chipping away at our
two car payments and then we will be
debt free we are in the military and as
you know there is a certain rank
structure in the military but my
question is how do I respectfully
respond when my leadership is pressuring
me into spending money on things that I
don't necessarily want to spend money on
so for example this year's Christmas
party was fifty dollars a ticket for me
and my husband odo obviously would be a
hundred dollars we'd have to also pay
for a babysitter when I said I didn't
want to go I kind of got a lot of
pressure from my upper leadership
telling me things like if I don't go
then my subordinates aren't going to go
and how does that make me look another
example is during Kovac just this past
two weeks ago we had a baby shower for
somebody at drive-by so we brought gifts
and dropping them at the end of the
driveway when I said I wasn't gonna go I
got a text message from my supervisor
saying how disappointed she was that I
couldn't even buy balloons or buy
diapers that type of thing and I have no
problem celebrating you know a baby or
celebrating Christmas but with the plan
that we're on we're so close to reaching
our goal and I just my question is how
do I respond to them in a way that's
respectful and telling them that I want
to decide how I spend my money that it's
not up to them it sounds like that's the
bigger issue sounds like it's not about
the $15 pack of diapers with a bow on it
it sounds more that you don't like
somebody telling you what to do with
your money is that it the babies to
issue in more of a I'm in the military
you deal you tell me what to do with
every moment of my life and I don't want
you deal and tell me this moment - is
that more it I think that's I think
that's part of it but mostly I just feel
like my family is on a plan and we're on
track and I really want to meet that
goal and I
like that there I guess I don't like
that they're kind of telling me like no
you will spend money on this one I could
take that hundred dollars that I would
have stayed for those tickets to the
Christmas party and put it towards my
car long yeah I've got an opinion on it
what do you think Dave my opinion on it
is this your it's just a social norming
question and so if being the contrarian
being someone who is comfortable saying
that's not me and that's not what we're
gonna do with our money we don't want to
do that then don't do it and then goes
back to something I say all the time
which is your boss doesn't get a vote
the other side of it is which this is
the way I've tended to do these kind of
things is I build it into my budget and
it's as a as a cost of doing business at
the place where I work there's some
social norms there that everybody
pitches in into a pot for weddings
everybody pitches into a pot for babies
and this isn't that what I won't do is
feel bad either way I'm not gonna give
somebody else permission to make me
question my values or make question the
decisions me and my wife make together
about our family's finances pick one of
those two sides and and and go with it
what do you think Dave as a person as a
leader I've got a thousand folks on this
team I don't mind
ever someone disagreeing with something
they're asked to do that's outside of
their job what I do mind is them being
disagreeable when they're disagreeing so
to be real honest grace Europe you're a
little torqued about this it's in your
voice you're a little put out and I
don't think you're wrong for being put
out but if your supervisor hears that
same thing in your response you're going
to limit the effectiveness of
respectfully disagreeing right and so
you need to just kind of pray through
and get your name back grace and just go
you know I'm kind of scared to bring
this up with you sergeant or lieutenant
or captain or whatever because I'm
afraid that you might be mad at me
you might think I'm insubordinate but
I'm working really hard to pay off my
cars over here I just can't do it this
year I'm so sorry I don't want to be a
bad leader I don't want to not be what
you want me to be but we've got these
family goals and we're just not gonna be
able to it I'm just so sorry and if you
go at it that way most people will let
you off the hook now if you're dealing
with a turkey but they're just gonna be
a turkey but you can't control that but
that you know the way you ask or the way
you respond it's not asking it's just
responding and just say I'm not doing it
but if you go I'm not doing it it's none
of your business what I do with my money
kick you know kiss my butt
yeah that uh no that's not work I feel
that I can feel that inside but I just
have to stop and go okay I'm dealing
with a personal Authority and in the
military
virtually absolute authority over you
and you're used to taking direct you
know orders commands and that's how
you're trained and that's how they're
trained for you to take them so you just
kind of go hey join me on my goal to get
my car's paid off understand my heart
and it's not a heart of rebellion or
belligerence or a heart of whatever and
and then just say I'm not I can't do it
because my husband we've agreed to this
and it's just really really important to
us I hope you understand I pray you
understand because we're not doing it
and then you can't you can't own the the
hurt feelings on the back end of it yeah
if they decide to be a but it is now
their decision that's what it is that's
right but don't you know make sure you
pray about this a little bit before you
go in there would they get that edge of
your voice and iron I don't blame you
for having the edge but it's just not
gonna be productive